in this video I want to talk about
transcription initiation in eukaryotes
now in this one specifically we're going
to do it for mRNA so it's the initiation
of mRNA transcription in eukaryotes and
I wrote here beware silliness ahead I
might say some silly things in this
video so I apologize in advance if
that's off-putting anybody okay so the
first thing that's going to happen is
that if we have DNA DNA has the Tata box
in the promoter region of eukaryotes so
the first thing that's going to happen
is transcription factor 2d is going to
bind the tata box now how can it do that
transcription factor 2d contains this
thing tbp now EBP is this thing called
the tata binding protein so that tata
binding protein is what allows
transcription factor 2d to actually bind
the tata box upon binding the tata box
the tin scratches come factor 2d after
it binds it recruits RNA polymerase 2
along with some transcription factors
with it to the tata box and this region
here so RNA polymerase and transcription
factors 2 h e F a and B all join to form
this thing called the pre initiation
complex it's also known as the basal
complex so how do you remember these
details
well the way I remember it is well its
transcription factors 2 h e F a and B
and they're coming in with RNA
polymerase 2 well for me it's not too
difficult to understand that RNA
polymerase Tuesday come in because I
already know that I'm talking about mRNA
transcription the way I think about or
the way I remember which transcription
factors come in is we're about to start
a party we're about to transcribe some
mRNA party time so he fab joins the
party
he's fabulous and he's ready to party ok
so that might be a little silly to some
of you but that's the way I remember
about which transcription factors are
coming here ok now
pre-initiation complex what that allows
for is it's basically stabilizes the
helix and begins to open it up and get
it ready for transcription so this year
is now the open complex that I want to
note here the open complex once that
complex is stabilized and open and ready
to go
HB and E those three transcription
factors leave transcription factors to H
B and E leave the complex so how do I
remember that the way I remember that is
gonna get rid of that orange there so
after joining the party and opening
things up he decides he no longer wants
to stay so he be exiting he leaves H B
and E leave okay here H F a and B joined
the party and now H B and E he'd be
exiting they all leave the party okay so
RNA polymerase 2 then its CTD or carboxy
terminal domain is phosphorylated so
what is
carboxy terminal domain well RNA
polymerase is a protein and proteins are
made up of long strings of amino acids
you know amino acid chains polypeptide
chains have amino terminus and or an
amino terminus rather and a carboxy
terminus so it's carboxy terminal domain
is phosphorylated once that happens
transcription is initiated it can go so
transcription begins so then what
happens
so transcription factor to two
transcription factors DNA stay at the
tata box so the way I remember that is
this might be a little bit silly but I
think ah you stay here again a sort of
Arnold Schwarzenegger voice I just think
of a terminator what I think about this
step here against super silly but if
that's how that helps me remember
hopefully that silly joke helps meet you
too so transcription factors 2d and a
both stay at the tata box then RNA
polymerase 2 along with the only
transcription factor left here other
than these two and the ones that left is
F RNA polymerase 2 and transcription
factor 2 F continued synthesis until a
termination site is reached so they're
synthesizing the mRNA and they're going
to keep going until a termination site
is reached at which point the RNA
polymerase 2 will fall off that's pretty
much it as far as initiation of
transcription of mRNA in eukaryotes
I apologize for anyone who didn't like
to say Linnaeus but if you did like it
I'm happy about that and happy studying
hope that video was helpful one last
thing I'm a tutor if you live in
Southern California feel free to contact
me via email at moose University at
gmail.com see the description below for
more details thank you for watching and
putting up with my silliness